hey colada fans this is John Roca Damien
Chazelle is back with another possible
Best Picture contender this month with
first man the film stars Ryan Gosling
his real-life astronaut Neil Armstrong
and Claire Foy as his wife Janet
Armstrong Neil famously said when he was
the first person to walk on the moon on
July 20th 1969 he walked on the moon I
mean what did you do today it's an
intense exploration of this man's
journey into the unknown of space and
what effect it had on his family and on
the space program in general films
gotten some great early buzz and those
trailers have inspired us here at
Collider to count down our top 5
astronaut movies so sit back strap in do
your systems check start those thrusters
and let's launch this countdown in 3 2 1
liftoff all right our number 5 astronaut
movie is the right stuff this 1983
masterpiece from director Philip Kaufman
clocks in at 3 hours and 13 minutes
without an intermission
but it never feels it's length the film
is based on Tom Wolf's book that details
the story of the original mercury 7
astronauts during the first 15 years of
America's space program it focuses on
the lives of these men and their wives
as they confronted the dangers
frustrations and successes during the
early days of NASA and how those
experiences affected their families
during a time in our country's history
where political turmoil and unrest was
going hand-in-hand with rapid
technological innovation the film stars
Ed Harris John Glenn Scott Glenn is Alan
Shepard Sam Shepard is Chuck Yeager
alongside a constellation of notable
actors like Dennis Quaid Barbara Hershey
Jeff Goldblum Fred Ward Harry Shearer
Kim Stanley Veronica Cartwright Pamela
Reed and Kathy Baker the film was
nominated for eight Oscars and took home
four of them for Best Original Score
best film editing best sound and best
sound effects editing trust me when you
watch the film you'll understand why I
deserved all those nominations our
number four movie is 2013's gravity from
noted Mexican film director Alfonso
Cuaron the film stars Sandra Bullock as
dr. Ryan stone a medical engineer on her
first shuttle mission alongside veteran
astronaut matt kowalski played
George Clooney but we find out is
captaining his last spaceflight before
settling into retirement as they engaged
in some fun banter that gives us a
window into their friendship and a
slight peek into the inner emotional
turmoil bollocks dr. stone is
experiencing disaster strikes during a
routine spacewalk when their space
shuttle is destroyed mid orbit stone and
Kowalski are left stranded in deep space
without a comms link to earth and soon
discover that they may have the venture
deeper into space in order to find their
way back home it's an incredible film
with overwhelming visuals that puts the
viewer authentically in the place of the
two main actors as they experience all
their fear and panic before that ending
Bullock is exceptional here and it's
this viewers favorite role that she's
ever done the end of the movie has some
powerful symbolism that divided
audiences and asked us to decide if
Bullock is actually deceased or reborn
interstellar is the number three movie
on our list this existential exploration
of the power of love versus time comes
from director Christopher Nolan and
stars Matthew McConaughey Anne Hathaway
Jessica Chastain Casey Affleck Ellen
Burstyn and the voice of Bill Irwin the
film is set in the future on an earth
that is nearing its demise and needs a
team of astronauts to venture into a
wormhole to search for a new home for
Humanity along the way they experience
some weird-ass changes in time from
space to the surface of planets and evil
a.f Matt Damon and a wormhole that lets
McConaughey communicate his message of
love to his daughter in the past written
by Nolan and his brother Jonathan Nolan
of HBO's Westworld the film was shot in
35 millimeter in anamorphic format and
IMAX 70 millimeter making it damn
gorgeous to look at it won the Academy
Award for Best Visual Effects and was
nominated for Best Original Score best
sound mixing best sound editing and best
production design it's also another
astronaut movie with a divisive ending
that sent people out of the feet of
grumbling or marveling at the Nolan's at
decision
I'm sensing a theme here Houston we do
not have a problem with the number two
film on our list
Apollo 13 Oh God that was a dad joke
wasn't it oh yes absolutely
I'll just see myself out now but wait I
I need to tell you about this film it's
a dramatization of the real-life aborted
1970 Apollo 13 lunar mission based on
astronaut Jim Lovell and Jeffrey
cloggers book lost moon in the perilous
voyage of Apollo 13 Tom Hanks leads an
all-star cast as Lovell and is joined by
Kevin Bacon Bill Paxton Kathleen Quinlan
and the great Ed Harris it was nominated
for nine Academy Awards including Best
Picture and one for best film editing
and best sound the mission was intended
to be the u.s. as third moon landing but
an onboard explosion depletes the crews
oxygen supply and electric power forcing
NASA abort the intended moon landing and
focus instead on bringing the crew
safely back to earth now they lose Gary
Sinise before they even leave the ground
and it's a harbinger of all the
obstacles they'll have to overcome in
order to get back home
hank shines as Lovell and keeps a calm
strong demeanor as he sciences the [ __ ]
out of their situation every step of the
way and gets them home and at number one
on our top five astronaut movies is
start the also sprach zarathustra strong
please 2001 a Space Odyssey from the
late and undeniably great Stanley
Kubrick this 1968 film is considered by
many film critics as the greatest
science fiction film ever made the fact
that Kubrick wrote it with noted sci-fi
author arthur c clarke probably has
something to do with that the film
starts out at the dawn of man where a
monolith sparks a blood feud between two
tribes of early man that ends with a
bone being thrown in the air as the film
shifts to a space mission to Jupiter the
mission takes the viewer into a head
trip that includes a calmly evil
sentient computer named pal trying to
kill its entire crew of astronauts led
by kir Julia as dr. Dave Bowman before
it can complete its mission so it
becomes a war of wills between Bowman
and how that is harrowing and ignites
fears in the viewer about the possibly
futile effort of humans to control the
technology they
oh and we also get a minutes long silent
trip into a black hole that leaves some
crazy head trippin time jumpin very late
60s visuals that ends with an insanely
large space baby again a divisive anthem
the film was nominated for four Academy
Awards and Kubrick even received an
Oscar for direction of visual effects
and it damn well deserves it
well we've landed back on Earth and
that's our top 5 astronaut movies let us
know what you think about this list the
order of this list and if there were
other movies that you would have put on
this list in the comments section below
remember to like and share this video on
your social media and subscribe to our
Collider quick channel for more content
just like this first man is coming soon
in theaters nationwide so enjoy the film
and let us know where you'd put it on
this list
you